so you want to optimize the capabilities
of your m2 macbook air well i have you
covered with the top must-have
accessories that won't break the bank
the one of which is actually free now
i'm not going to waste your time on
obvious things such as airpods and mice
we're gonna get into what is worth it
after these things have been tested and
why they are better than the competition
so let's jump right in the first one is
from our sponsor basis with their blade
100 watt usb type-c portable laptop
power bank now i have owned a ton of
power banks and this one stands out for
three reasons first it fast charges the
m2 macbook air through usb type c or
with the max 8 cable so if you didn't
get that one from apple this will do it
and second it puts out a hundred watts
meaning not only will your macbook air
fast charge but you could still charge
up your iphone or other devices and the
basis auto split chip will optimize
charging for all your devices that are
plugged in and make sure they are safe
so they're not overcharged it has four
ports instead of two and all four of
them are fast charge capable compared to
others well they'll have one that
supports the full speed now the other
great thing is that it is super slim so
it doesn't bulk up my bag and they do
include a 100 watt rated usbc cable and
it also can be fast charged in just one
and a half hours using only a 65 watt
adapter i really like that the led
display will not only show you how long
it will take to charge up but also how
long it will last while you're powering
and charging your devices as well as
other info it's already a great price
but you can use our exclusive code and
link in the description for the best
price online next is this super small
fast charger from anchor if you didn't
get a fast charger from apple you are
going to take over an hour just to get
to 50
compared to 30 minutes not only that
comparing the anchor to apple's charger
i mean there's a massive difference in
size and you can pick this up for only
35 bucks so it is a no-brainer and then
of course you can use it to charge up
this power bank super quickly as well so
i think it's a must-have for any m2
macbook air owner the next one you will
probably laugh at and that is because it
is a laptop cooler now when i bought
this i thought it was going to be a joke
i just wanted to test it out for a
previous video but it made a dramatic
difference compared to using the m2
macbook air by itself and it plugs in
with a usb port uses barely any power
and it runs really quiet so if you are
at your desk and you are working on some
tougher stuff or you just want your
laptop to stay cool because it's fanless
you can pick up one of these for super
cheap and it does help now if you pair
it with one of these thermal pads the
difference is shocking it pretty much
becomes an m2 macbook pro
but you know you get the new form factor
with a new design now this transfers
heat from that chip which is sealed in
and then to the bottom a plate of the
laptop and then the cooler can cool it
down if you want to use it together now
if you care about longevity
if you care about best performance i
mean i would consider using one of these
and don't worry about the thermal pads
messing up your battery some people have
talked about that apple controls
everything and everything is in spec
so that's enough about that but the next
one i will let you guys know if you
don't want to mess with thermal pads or
anything like that is this thing it has
been on here the whole time it is a slim
as a credit card and this is from mocked
we've shown off their other products
before so not only is it a stand you can
go up to 25 degrees to get a nicer kind
of typing experience or you can actually
lift it up even higher than that which i
think is great and i use for zoom calls
face times because when a laptop is
sitting on your desk you're recording
yourself up you're seeing the ceiling
you're looking up your nose compared to
a much more natural position like this
now the kicker is that this thing uses
graphene which is amazingly effective at
wicking out heat so instead of the cpu
having a hotspot and getting super quick
it will spread out in the chassis and on
the graphene pad and it is very
inexpensive
one great thing is that you can take it
off and keep reapplying it which is
great because i ended up putting on
backwards my first time if you're buying
one of these m2 macbook airs and you do
any sort of creative work or even
security cameras any of that stuff you
might need a card reader it's a shame
apple didn't include one because even
the old macbook air has had it
but this thing is inexpensive it looks
great and it is actually faster than the
sd card reader that's built into the 14
and 16 inch macbook pros on top of that
it also has a micro sd card slot so you
have ultimate flexibility next we have
this bad boy right over here if you
purchase an m2 air with base storage or
even 512 you'll likely need more storage
and a lot of people suggest the samsung
t5 but that is expensive for what you
get this sabrint we've been using it and
recommending it for years now it's a
little bit more money but it gets up to
five times faster and it is backwards
compatible with thunderbolt with usb
type-c it has great protection and has
really really high soc cache so you can
actually buy one of these instead of
upgrading your ssd say to one terabyte
or two use it on a lot of machines and
the performance is really great so we
highly recommend these now if you don't
need speed or that pushes your budget
we have this sandisk little thumb drive
now i love things that are compatible
with a lot of devices which is why i
like this thing has usb type a and usb
type c it is very cheap even for 256
gigabytes so you can toss this in your
bag it is tiny and store extra files or
backup to it the other thing that
everybody needs is a usbc to usb a
adapter now you can buy one of these for
20 bucks from apple or you can save some
money buy this for 14 bucks and the
speeds that you get from it are way
better you have four different ports
full 10 gigabit per second it is just an
incredible value so you might as well
get that one now if you can spend a
little bit more money you can pick up
the upgraded version that has three usb
a ports it has a usbc for pass-through
charging and an hdmi that supports hdcp
2.2 so that you can watch netflix
through it it's made out of metal and it
is really high quality so you can't
really beat it now if you don't want to
worry about having multiple connections
and having an sd card we also have this
chargin pro
that supports 4k 60 it has an sd and
micro sd card built in you have usb a
ports that are full 10 gigabit per
second so this is the ultimate
powerhouse and it's only 85 bucks it's
not like a dock that costs 300 400 now
if you want a way to protect your m2
macbook air we have the slim sleeve for
it and not only is it a great price it
has a bunch of extra features first off
it has this little elastic section where
you can actually put something like an
adapter in there and it'll stretch out
it has a little section for cards and it
actually uses origami to achieve the
same thing like that stand does so you
can actually prop up your macbook at
multiple angles for face timing or for
typing and it is just super thin as well
so if you want something that is budget
but has a lot of different capabilities
and uses not just a little pouch this is
the way to go now if you're going to be
at your desk and you need a stand that's
more permanent my favorite is the book
arc from 12 south i've used this for
years and it fits your macbook perfectly
in it it raises it up so you have nice
airflow you can have it kind of sideways
like this so that doesn't take up too
much space and you have full access to
your ports so you can connect
they have different inserts for
different kind of laptops and it just
looks fantastic now if you are going to
be doing a desk setup you will likely
want more ports now i'm not a fan of the
three 400 ones that cost a lot give you
a bunch of stuff you don't need which is
why i love the owc thunderbolt 4 hub it
is thunderbolt 4 not 3 which means that
you could take just one port from your
m2 macbook air and split it out into
three full speed ports and i've had my
qnap connected a fast ssd and my 6k
display and none of them slowed down and
with that on the front you have a full
size usb a as well so this can charge up
your laptop and then provide you with
additional really fast expansion and
it's only 180 bucks it is not 300 or 400
and it has been working fantastic for a
couple of years now now the last one
that i want to mention
and it's not technically an accessory
but it's something that every macbook
air owner needs to know and that is the
low power mode now i made a dedicated
video about this going into detail but
the gist of it is when you toggle this
it uses mostly the efficiency cores and
the m2 chip has amazing efficiency cores
way better than anything else so still
super quick and you can get about 15
hours of battery life and your system
stays nice and cool so when for those
times where you don't need the ultimate
best performance you care about battery
life you have to know about this go
ahead and check it out so there you guys
go once again all the links are down in
the video description if you guys want
to check him out and if you guys want to
subscribe and you enjoy this video if it
was valuable click that circle above
check out one of those great videos
right over there this has been max and
i'll see you in the next video
[Music]
you